if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
dumps
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just
[Music]
big massive
[Music]
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once dumps
dumps
[Music]
what is going on here it's just beyond
parody
massive dumps cost of the election
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here what is going on
[Music]
dump big massive dumps
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we are down
to the last
43 hours and
hold on 43 hours and 23 43
23 minutes i believe until
the end finally of the official reign of
terror
of donald trump although as i saw
someone point out via twitch sub there
they believe that the trump madness may
only just
be starting i i tend to think that
that's probably the case
um i i believe that we are going to see
it's going to it's going to take a lot
of work
to even keep up with all of the
investigations that are going to take
place
into the trump organization trump's
family trump's
kids trump's associates it's going to be
absolutely insane
uh but at least we will have someone
different in charge and we're standing
by for that 43 hours and 22 minutes to
go
and i will be with you in 42 hours and
22 minutes 11 a.m eastern
time wednesday morning 8 a.m
in the west very early for some of our
west coast listeners
uh for the inauguration of president joe
biden so much to do
and even at this late stage there is
vetting happening by the fbi
of the national guard troops that will
be assigned
to protect the capital in washington dc
for fears of possible insider trump
loyalists so we're going to get that
we have a report about that from the
associated press
and so many different things going on we
are standing by for pardons
tomorrow tuesday expecting massive
dumps of pardons from donald trump as
many as
100 pardons unclear
at this point whether trump will try to
pardon himself i'm leaning towards
no and whether trump will issue
pre-emptive blanket pardons for some of
his family
i'm probably leaning towards yes on that
side
and we're going to look at some videos
coming up from rudy giuliani
we're going to look at some news max and
oan video
on the subject so just so many different
things going on and i'm glad that you
are
joining me uh as some of you have
noticed
patrons members twitch why
i don't know uh this is i believe the
last stream before the inauguration
so we're doing something a little wacky
patrons will count
towards today's goal of 232
which is both the number of electoral
votes trump had in the november election
and the number of house members that
voted to impeach him
just days ago so a lot of meaning to the
number 232
as always members count today
twitch subs count today but also right
here
patrons counting just for kicks i don't
know
i don't know what what we're doing jacob
ratner says thoughts on the wacky
attempt to impeach biden by the cue
congresswoman yeah we covered that last
week
my thoughts are in that video i think
she's out of her mind and we'll be
talking more about
uh marjorie taylor greene as well as
lauren bobert
i i call her i say bobert lauren bobert
we will talking about her
uh tomorrow as well and also a super
chat from robert havens who says
trump wants a two billion dollar library
he may get the one in leavenworth
renovated so he can visit it
um yeah the the idea of a library for a
president who hasn't read a book in his
adult life the irony of that is not lost
on me and and as i tweeted earlier
generally the idea of a trump library is
funny but i'm sure
that the details of the trump library if
it should exist
will also be extra funny unclear whether
they will have a crayon station
at the trump library but it remains to
be seen
can i explain pardons do they deal with
civil matters as well
no they deal with federal criminal
matters
if you have a preemptive pardon you
still can be sued
no question about that is a criminal
pardon for everything or only a specific
crime you can issue a preemptive blanket
pardon as president and it would be a
umbrella pardon for crimes committed
up until that date if you after the
pardon go and commit crimes
it wouldn't it wouldn't cover you it's
insane for sure
joe says soon i will be connected to
spacex's starlink high-speed internet
service
and beaming the david pakman show
through outer space
i love that i love that and a sinful
solution
says that uh right side broadcasting
still had live chat
filled with q anon morons yeah we're
going to be dealing with q anon for
for quite a period of time so that's no
no surprise whatsoever big thank you to
nrg238 who just made
a pledge at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow thanks nrg and
also a big thank you who's this martin
romero
for signing up at joinpackman.com
appreciate that
and also an extra special thank you to
the 13 people who just grabbed twitch
prime and twitch
standard subscriptions very much
appreciate that
okay let's get into some stuff um
oh i see people asking if i'm gonna talk
about the glenn greenwald drama
i'm not going to if you are curious
about
about this uh glenn greenwald
kind of attacked me yesterday on twitter
and
um i'm not gonna get into it on stream
and and honestly the reason there's only
i would love to do it you know that when
jimmy dore
attacked me and others i did get into it
on on twitter
the reason i don't want to do it is i i
think something's up with with glenn i
think glenn is not doing well personally
i think he has personal stuff going on
and it has led to a glenn greenwald that
i quite frankly don't recognize
um and something about it just
it's not feeling like the type of thing
where i want to take it head on
on stream because i i feel like
something is
up and i'm not i just wouldn't feel
right about it
so if you're curious about what went
down yesterday you can look at it on my
twitter but i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna deal with it on stream
today okay the big news
is that the fbi is vetting national
guard
troops in washington dc amid
fears of an insider attack imagine
what's going on right now that this is
what has to take place
u.s defense officials say they're
worried about an insider attack
or other threat from service members
involved in securing joe biden's
inaugural
prompting the fbi to vet all of the 25
000 national guard troops coming into dc
people are saying what does that mean
it means to examine and verify that
these are individuals who will actually
be loyal to the us
in protecting the capital and joe biden
rather than to trumpian delusions
the massive undertaking reflects the
extraordinary security concerns that
have gripped washington
following the trump riot in the u.s
capitol
it underscores fears that some of the
very people assigned
to protect the city over the next
several days
could present a threat to the incoming
president
and other vips in attendance imagine
that
we need to protect ourselves from the
protectors
army secretary ryan mccarthy told the ap
that officials are conscious of the
threat
he warned commanders to be on the
lookout for problems within ranks
so far he and other leaders say they
have seen no evidence of any threats and
officials said the vetting
hasn't flagged any issues they are aware
of that's good
about 25 000 members of the national
guard are streaming into washington from
across the country
at least two and a half times the number
for previous inaugurals while the
military routinely interviews uh reviews
sorry
service members for extremist
connections the fbi screening is in
addition to any previous
monitoring multiple officials said this
started as the first guard troops began
deploying to dc
more than a week ago and they said it is
slated to be complete by wednesday
several officials discussed military
planning
on condition of anonymity the question
is is that all of them
are there others we need to be conscious
of it and we need to put
all of the mechanisms in place to
thoroughly vet
these men and women who would support
any operation like this
what does vetting mean in a situation
like this fbi vetting would involve
running people's names
through databases and watch lists
maintained by the bureau
to see if anything alarming comes up
that could include involvement in prior
investigations or terrorism-related
concerns
said david gomez former fbi national
security supervisor in seattle
um this is this it's crazy that this is
where we are today
but it is where we are today and i would
rather it be done and be sad that we
need it
rather than not doing it when it clearly
is something that is necessary so
i believe that that process is going to
happen without incident i don't believe
we are going to have any kind of
insider attack on the inauguration
on wednesday if people disagree with me
i would love to hear from you as far as
that goes i did say by the way i don't
know if you how many of you follow me on
twitter
but i did say earlier with all of these
national guard troops having to sleep on
the floor of the capitol to protect it
from trumpist riders
you'd think the my pillow guy would at
least have donated his pillows to them
but no he had instead
a piece of paper which had the words
martial law on it
um which was photographed as he was on
his way in
to meet with donald trump a few days ago
so
still the possibility that trump is
thinking about considering
whether he could do some kind of wacky
thing in
at this very very late stage but it is
absolutely insane
what is going on okay so that's fbi
vetting guard troops in dc also now
we have this possibility of trump
massively dumping pardons on the country
let's take a look at this new york times
allies
uh a new york times article about
trump's allies
the president's allies have collected
tens of thousands of dollars and
potentially much more from people
seeking pardons
can you imagine oh sorry about that
i had voicemail rigged up to play some
voicemails for you later and someone's
calling in i'm gonna mute that
until later as president trump prepares
to leave office in days
a lucrative market for pardons is coming
to a head
with some of his allies collecting fees
listen to this from wealthy felons or
their associates
to push the white house for clemency
according to documents and interviews
with more than three dozen lobbyists and
lawyers
the brisk market i for i for a second
thought i said the brisket market i
would have had a lot to say about the
brisket market
the brisk market for pardons reflects
the access peddling
that has defined mr trump's presidency
as well as his unorthodox approach to
exercising unchecked clemency powers
pardons and commutations are intended to
show mercy to deserving recipients but
trump has used them to reward
personal or political allies the part i
wanted to get to was this
mr trump's former personal lawyer john
dowd has marketed himself to convicted
felons as someone
who could secure pardons because of his
close relationship with the president
accepting tens of thousands of dollars
from a wealthy felon by the way a
wealthy felon is only paying
20 or 30 grand that seems low that
actually seems low to me
tens of thousands of dollars from a
wealthy felon and advising him
and other potential clients to leverage
trump's grievances about the justice
system
this is the the best part a one-time top
advisor to the trump campaign
was paid 50 grand to help seek a pardon
for john kiriakou
a former cia officer convicted of
illegally disclosing classified
information
and agreed to a 50 000 bonus if the
president granted it okay so that's an
interesting deal
50 grand down 50 grand for performance
all right that's not that's a nice
consulting gig mr kiriakou
was separately told that trump's
personal lawyer
rudolph w giuliani could help him secure
a pardon for two million right
rudy is taking so that's an interesting
that's an interesting angle so
there's kind of two ways it's sort of
like when you go in and you want to
uh you know you want to get a new car
you could do a trade-in
or not you could lease or you could pay
cash or you could finance and if you
finance you can do
you know a month or whatever okay one
deal is
50 down 50 if i get you the pardon the
50 the initial 50 is speculative though
or you can go to rudy and just give him
2 million and he says it's a guarantee
now who would believe that
if rudy at this point given how he's
disgraced himself said
i can guarantee a pardon i would say no
you can't rudy
you can't you can't even guarantee that
you're going to have a a
20-minute press conference without your
head melting how could you guarantee a
presidential pardon it makes no sense
but anyway
kiriakou says rudy said for two million
i can secure it
but kyriakou rejected it but an
associate fearing giuliani was illegally
selling pardons
alerted the fbi giuliani challenged the
characterization now what i love about
that is
rudy is not saying it didn't happen
rudy is not saying there was not a
discussion of money and pardons rudy is
saying
that the characterization he rejects
okay not not a very strong
denial from rudy giuliani so that's
what's happening
uh from the standpoint of pardons
at this point in time um
okay oh i'm
sorry i i mean i know i'm supposed to
thank people hold on
um i want to say 13
big thank yous to twitch subscribers
putting us at 28.
i also want to say thank you to brad
lawyer
cr and chris mcnair for signing up at
joinpackman.com and
very special today patreon counts
minna weisberger has just pledged on
patreon
megan munger has just pledged
ed roper has pledged and recharge
zone has pledged putting us at 34. yes
if you're wondering where where is this
patreon stuff coming from
we're counting patreon today patreon
counts just to make it even more likely
that we get to uh 242 232 rather
all right a few other super chats do you
think
trump will pardon his children i think
it's more likely he pardons them
then he pardons himself
um oh yeah phil spector phil spector uh
passing away
one of the most interesting photographs
i've ever seen
is phil spector in court
uh i i have never seen anything like
this
uh hold on a second where is that image
here it is look at that um that
i have never i don't you know i've had
some really weird things happen to my
hair
i have never seen anything like this
it uh it almost seems fake
but it is very real and uh
yes the passing of phil spector
was it because of covet in prison or
what did he i don't even remember the
phil spector story did he not even go to
prison i don't know much about that
i know he was accused of killing his
wife
yes it was covid but was it in prison
died in prison of covet okay they're not
saying it was coveted
but i thought they were saying that all
right very good wil will be like
thanksgiving in january if trump pardons
these turkeys yes
well said well said david did you see my
music video music video of massive dumps
featuring you on the drums the trump's
massive dumps
featuring david pakman i don't i don't
think i did but maybe i did we get a lot
of stuff so it's just stuff
tough to keep up with it hey friend i've
joined up with the young turks brian
tyler cohen and you in these past
six months good company thank you
seymour i appreciate that
and do trump's pardons after being
impeached count if he's convicted
uh that's a great question i think the
answer is yes as long as he issues them
before being convicted which obviously
he would
if he does it tomorrow mcconnell
endorsing the
impeachment to occupy the senate into
biden's hundred days
and hinder biden's moves critical times
and then use
this against biden i'm not totally sure
i know what you mean frederick but
but i do think that you're right in
thinking that mitch mcconnell has
personal reasons for why he's okay with
the trump impeachment
is it legal that people are collecting
money to advocate to trump for a pardon
you know it seems like it shouldn't be
legal
but i don't know if it's if it's being
done away that by the letter of the law
it it's going it's acceptable i
genuinely it should be illegal
but uh i i don't know beyond that
uh we'll have to get a legal take on
that i think is the right way to say it
okay i have a clip from newsmax
and a clip from oan that i want to
review with you guys
but i also i saw that we have 220
voicemails from over there no i'm sorry
260 voicemails from over the weekend
and i haven't reviewed them but i'd be
willing to look through
to see if any of our you know friends
that we've gotten to know
have left any voicemails what do people
want i'll do it all but what do people
want first
voicemails oan newsmax
i'm glad to go in any direction
a lot of calls for oan first
all right let's let's check out oan
first where did i have that
uh not here this is this is newsmax for
later this is newsmax
oh okay oh right dennis frager
the guy from uh prager university he was
interviewed
on oan and i guess it's crazy
and he's talking about
pseudo-intellectualism like it's a
problem on the left which of course
we followed right you know this is
actually an academic issue
so you know one of the things that the
right sometimes will do well
and by well i mean i mean it's
pernicious but they'll do it well
they will send they'll project that i
mean i actually don't need to do that
much of an explanation the right will
take something that is actually an issue
on their side
and they will pretend like it's an issue
on the left and a great example of that
is you know there's all this academic
work about
pseudo and anti-intellectualism on the
american right for a very very long time
and appealing to
uh appealing to uninformed people and
ignorant people so i haven't watched
this yet but i'm told it's wild
dennis prager goes on oan and says the
left
is uh a pseudo-intellectual let's take a
listen
it's quite a time that we live in that
now americans who used to be so
suspicious by the way the the hosting on
newsmax and oan
it seems satirical like it actually
seems like satire but i guess these are
real
news hosts anyway okay put it mildly of
government of any
uh power being concentrated in the hands
of the few and now as you're saying
you just see so many americans going
about their daily life going well the
quote-unquote experts told us this is
the way we have to live
the quote-unquote experts told us i have
to do a b and c
now this is interesting because again
they're taking something that is a real
issue
which is the the industry of so-called
experts
and so for example when you bring in a
neuroradiologist
to be the top doctor for your
administration on a communicable disease
what that's a red alert we should be
saying wait a second why should a
neuroradiologist whose expertise is in
looking at scans
be leading a pandemic response
so it's this crisis of expertise is real
but it's not the one they're pointing
out
and they just do it without asking too
many questions and and even when things
don't exactly
make sense they still unfortunately go
along with this so you actually make a
really good point about brainwashing
in your piece can you imagine frager
talking about brainwashing
you talk about and i'm quoting you said
that you didn't think that
you thought it could only happen in
totalitarian
governments totalitarian regimes and now
we're seeing it in anomaly
free country why exactly do you think
that is
this was another uh surprise to me yeah
so when i was a graduate student at
columbia
my i was by the way that okay i won't
even comment on that
yeah okay we can't get sidetracked what
they call the russian institute i
studied the communist countries
and i learned russian not in order to
order a cheese sandwich but
which most people do which is fine what
i i studied it solely to be able to read
pravda the soviet communist newspaper
which i got
to be able to read and
so my life has been sort of devoted to
reading
brainwashing kind of sad isn't it
news items if you will strange thing to
devote your life to but okay
oh columns and
i was sure most of my life you could
only brainwash a people in a tyranny
because there's free speech to
counteract right
what's crazy about this is he's wrong
we've seen the brainwashing of of
of america 75 million people voted for
trump a lot of that is cultish
brainwashing but again
they they all with a lot of these guys
like
if you just change this to be about the
trump movement
he would actually be putting together a
very good analysis
uh in a free press but the free press in
the united states the mainstream press
is pravda so whether or not they work
for the government
it's an equal brainwash the new york
times is essentially as honest as pravda
was
and the la times and the washington post
i just use new york times right
he's on oan he's on oan
which promoted every insane notion about
the election fraud that didn't happen
saying we can't trust these
investigative institutions think think
about the insanity the new york times
spread the biggest lie in american
history 1619 the country was founded
and uh we had a revolution against the
britain in order to
to maintain slavery liberal anti-trump
professors called it a lie
sean willins at princeton is one of them
just in case people want to look this up
it's a lying newspaper they all are they
all are
the president but he has nothing to say
about oan president
has been right president trump has been
right
in calling it the fake news media that
is exactly correct that is what
they are and uh i thought that was
restricted
solely to uh dictatorships i was wrong
and talking of the new york times as
we're discussing earlier with the soviet
union as well
they also covered up for the mass
humanitarian crimes that were happening
under stalin's leadership the mass
starvations that were taking place in
the ukraine
they had some of the reporters over
there being they're still calling it the
ukraine
driven around by the soviets living the
high life and they're like i don't see
anything wrong here everything everyone
looks fine to me they even wrote in some
of their articles that
people in the show this is one of those
this is this is also i mean this is
really a clinic and disinformation
the fact that stalinist communism was a
disaster
is not a defense of trump it's not a
it's not a defense of anything like who
very few people think stalinist
communism was good
why is it even the topic here union
specifically in
the ukraine they're hungry but they're
starving and that's how they tried to
play the game there unfortunately what
do you think about that
i've written about it a lot walter
durante got a pulitzer prize in 1932
he's the new york times correspondent in
moscow
stalin loved the man gave him a great
apartment
great life and it is exactly when
stalin was deliberately deliberately
starving millions of ukrainians to death
uh people i actually kind of missed how
why we're even i mean i guess
we're talking about this because he
learned russian but what is the other
why are we even talking about stalinist
russia people should read the red famine
by anne applebaum who for the record is
a never trumper
uh and uh i i don't agree with her on
politics but she wrote a true book about
what happened in ukraine
and people should know about that about
five to six million people
were slaughtered and and uh you will get
an idea of how awful it is to starve to
death
and how uh you end up eating human
beings when that is all there is to eat
this is what this was about
pseudo-intellectualism and somehow we're
on russian cannibalism
it's done and the pulitzer prize which
should have been returned by the new
york times
80 years ago and they still have kept it
the new york times has
two pulitzer prizes for pure lies
durantes in 32 and last year's
for the 1619 project this is the state
of journalism in the united states
and yet they're the ones that claim to
have all this the moral high ground when
they talk to us
americans all the time and that's that's
the craziest thing as you were just
discussing looking back at their history
over the years
when it comes down to it all the
brainwashing that we've seen this is
vomitous
the failing schools how can we have our
civil society
how can american voters make good
decisions this is what you call
a worthless interview this it's vapid
there's no substance of any kind here
at the ballot box and govern themselves
well and to be able to
choose wisely between candidates when we
lack the basic foundations of a solid
education
and in many cases so many people are
growing up even the see
so again this is where i'm gonna i'm
gonna get away from this because it is
it really
truly is uh uh nauseating but again
yeah we do have a real problem with
education if education
were better people wouldn't think this
was news if education were
better we wouldn't have anti-vaxx like
we have if education were better
fewer people would have fallen for the
trump uh nonsense if education were
better people wouldn't believe
tax cuts for the very rich are great for
the economy they are
identifying some of the real issues but
they're coming up with solutions that
are that are not
solutions uh it is it's it's puketastic
exactly as people are pointing out i
completely agree with you okay let me do
a couple other thank yous and then we'll
move on to some voicemails then i'll do
newsmax stuff
big thank you to denver button
who just signed up at joinpacman.com
anthony eckles
just signed up and ike escher just
signed up at
joinpackman.com also want to say thanks
to the three additional twitch
subscribers
and we are doing patreon today our
patreon
has been sad lately so we're doing
patreon
oh and sadly i have no one to thank
there that's a little embarrassing
but in any case for the people who
regularly join the chat
and say i'm already a website member and
a twitch subscriber what can i do
today is a day for patreon at
patreon.com
davidpakmajo it counts very sad
patreon yeah okay let's get to some
voicemails i want to see what our
trumpian friends
had to say over the weekend now i have
262 new voicemails
i'm gonna just take a scan to see if i
can find
any of our trumpian friends who called
in um it'll just take me a moment
because i've not had time to do this
um okay i do okay i've got a troy york
one
i've got a troy york one let's take a
listen to this
oh sorry hold on it's muted
i just come oh is that a new name bozo
bosworth i want to see that again hold
on let me refresh that i want to get to
the
i don't want to miss another fake name
that troy york is using here let's see
uh where did that go
okay here we go let's take a listen hey
david pakman this is ryan bozo bosworth
i just commented on your youtube channel
um
i just wanna know i i know you're
argentine um but are you smoking some
benzone layla and hash
no no no no i'm not no mexican marijuana
i mean what what the hell
are you talking about that the
reactionary right is
and trump supporters are more
predisposed to violence i mean yes
that's that's true
that's widely documented you're like hi
and not around all summer
were you on vacation um were those trump
supporters who were
protesting george floyd for like three
or four months
were these right-wing reactionaries oh
come on
let me ask you mr packman are you
on hardcore drugs right now as you make
your youtube videos
no i'm not thank you if anyone's more or
any group political group is more
paranoid thinking people are out to get
them
schizophrenic did you did you hear about
the january 6th riots
mistrusting fearful it is
the group you belong to um the left-wing
antifa
fascists what's interesting about that
is
i often get criticized because i'm not
supportive of antifa's methods
in many cases um
you are a troll you are a nerd
you are a zero nerd maybe i would accept
that
uh you are a loser you are a
propagandist or a foreigner
yes i am that is true so we're we're
we're touching on
elements that are i am foreign i was
born in a different country
you are a rant think you are unfunny
you are unclever unclever
um and you add nothing to the discussion
on your program stink you're nothing
like patrick henningsen of the sunday
liar
i love that he always mentions these
shows i've never heard of
like the botched twins what it what is
that one he mentioned sometimes the
botched twins
the dodge twins
what can someone remind me what that one
is that this guy mentions all the time
the hodge twins yes he mentions the
hodge twins
and then he mentions a lot of people
that the names sound like serial killers
you know how a lot of serial killers
have like their their middle name is
prominent in how we know them
and now i'm forgetting all of them but
he'll mention he'll mention youtubers
that i've never heard of who have names
that sound like serial killers
okay let's continue and jesse lee
peterson
or brian anthony logan there it is brian
brian anthony logan that i don't know i
have no idea who that is but there's an
example of that
um john wayne gacy exactly
that's when he when he's mentioning
people to me i'm thinking of john
wayne gacy exactly just everything you
say
in this uh video uh
about uh the predisposition for violence
in capitol hill
the stormy at capitol hill is a complete
fabrication and lie
again you say nothing of the 60 to 70
days
just in portland of the attack on the
federal courthouse
okay all right so let's go that's one
let me see what else came in again i
i have almost 300 new voicemails that
came in
and i'm just taking a look at uh
i think this is another troy york one
let's see mr pacman
harvard professor nope that's actually
someone else
uh let me see here
uh what else do maybe i don't have that
many trumpy voicemails from
over the weekend they may be quiet
because of the impending
departure of trump um just looking i
mean there's just you know when you have
262 voicemails there's a lot
um oh okay so here's another troy york
one left under his italian
character jacoby genovese
um let's let's listen hi
david mike ah this is jacoby genovese uh
calling from australia okay so this is
an italian australian
and uh you know i'm not american and i
shouldn't be
all commenting imagine being a fully
grown adult and leaving
10 of these a week on my voicemail
american politics but i will anyway
um i just wanted to say i was watching
uh jimmy doris program and he had the
great chris
hedges on your pro on his program um
who by the way i think would be a great
guest on your program
and uh chris hedges and jimmy dore uh
basically we're saying that
the left um guys i have to admit
something
this is just hatred male guy who i pay
to leave these voicemails
it there's no there's really no troy
york
isn't that sad i'm kidding there is a
troy york and we know exactly who he is
let's continue oh it's all frozen on big
social media
they just think that like by banning
people on social media that these
other americans are just going to go
away and and they won't
like you know what's interesting about
that disinformation on twitter
is down 73 percent election related
disinformation is down
73 percent since trump was banned
because it had such a
a trickle-down effect for lack of a
better term it's in
that doesn't mean it's right or wrong
even be part of the scene and i think
it's very naive
and heartening disheartening to see
all liberals in the left this one's very
boring okay let's see if he has any
other material
um let's see
hello david no that's actually someone
else
uh let's see if i've got it we're gonna
move on from this i know some people
hate the voicemails and some people love
the voicemails
well i'm just kind of doing this is
useful because i'd have to do this for
tomorrow anyway running through
all the different voicemails that came
in um
let's see
uh maybe that's it maybe okay yeah i
don't think i've got anything else okay
yeah it's starting to hurt the brain a
little so we'll we'll get away from it
we'll get away from it
okay um kyle hopper says you're no john
wilkes booth or mark david chapman right
yeah exactly
exactly uh david i think we all agree
you should do at least one debate a
month
i think bozo bosworth was spotted in the
maz eisley cantina yes
of course from star wars the q anon
movement kind of reminded me of the tea
party movement who were
responsible who were a response to the
obama presidency
tea party people were also elected into
congress both wacky far-right groups
with non-existent grievances
yes there is definitely
mose eisley mose eisley there is
definitely a similarity there
i think that's absolutely true okay
let's go next to my news max clip of
rudy giuliani
before i do that i do want to say thank
you
to the 13 additional twitch subscribers
who signed up
putting us at 53 i also want to say
thanks to
tim gravette who signed up at
joinpackman.com and is number 54
and some new patrons uh new patrons
mr schnitlock is a new patron
aaron ray has pledged on patreon
keith ratner with the pledge loretta
green
and martin yelland love it putting us at
59.
did i see the j is for genius i did
that's actually
let's pull that up because i did want it
let's see how i can find that
uh jay genius
trump that's that's an incredible video
let me see if i can find that
uh oh here it is this this is just
stunning
let's take a look at it thank you
check this out this is thank you hold on
let me make sure we have the volume
right
the j and trump stands for genius my
friends thank you very much thank you
not stupid
donald trump is a genius that's what the
j stands for
there you go i mean it's really hard to
argue with that
that is a that is a great argument if
i've ever heard one the j
is for genius the j is for genius
okay this is rudy on newsmax
um i've not pre-screened this i've been
asked to look at it
let's um take a listen and see what
what this is all about all right so
let's talk about the future
because the president by the way can't
they properly mike these interviews
isn't new doesn't newsmax actually have
a budget okay and according to
more than one recent poll this sounds
like she's being picked up by rudy's mic
is still the person that most
republicans would like to see on the
ballot in 2024
will he run again well that's what
that's exactly what the impeachment's
about
impeachment is is not about
they don't even charge oh rudy's
confused time of incitement to riot is
so far beyond what he did
with enormous protections for free yeah
rudy had better hope that's true because
he was also there in sighting at the
same event
speech that it's almost imagine having
your co-conspirator defend you and
taking that seriously
hey you were part of the incitement with
trump why don't you come on and defend
trump as if you're an unbiased observer
idiotic to talk about it
i mean there's he didn't every law
professor that's
in the middle it actually does seem like
they only brought one microphone i see
the microphone on rudy's tie
she doesn't seem to have her own mic
it's weird for
like when ten years ago when we would go
interview a member of congress
we would even be able to bring two mics
middle of the road we'll tell you
it's a perfectly perfectly um
perfectly legal speech as for all the
rest incitement to riot virtually means
you know taking him into the riot you
know
come with me well he did say let's go
and i'm going with you he didn't go
but he did say that not not language
not even angry language so
is this part of the borat movie this
interview this was a setup
well mcconnell says he doesn't know how
he's going to vote which means
mcconnell might be leaning towards uh
actually convicting the president does
he want to do that does mcconnell want
to end the possibility of
how would how would rudy know that
mcconnell wants nothing to do with rudy
the president running again in 2024 i
can't speak for senator mcconnell
okay at least he's being truthful about
that we're disappointed and
very disappointed in the things that he
did the things that he said
he knows better he's a he's a smart
enough man or a
smart enough man to know that this this
uh
terrible thing that happened at the
capitol wasn't caused by the president
and who caused it this is a terrible
thing to do to a man
who served his country the way president
trump has would the president wouldn't
want to get in 2024
he don't know the president i mean i
can't say for sure
four years a long time but um
well they sure as heck think he wants to
run that's why they're doing this too
and it's maybe the only way they can
beat him because next time
he'll be for forewarned and forearmed
about
just exactly what four-armed like still
using these allusions to violence
they're trying to get away with and i
predict over the next year
a lot more information will come out
about about this he spent his whole
career acting unethically
and and misusing his son as a bag man to
collect
millions and millions from from that
these are all disproven
talking points crooked ukrainian
oligarch who was paying off joe he
wasn't paying off
the big guy was who's going to pay
hunter biden i feel sorry for hunter
biden
judy uh judy rudy's shirt tucked in
during this interview
he's been an addict all his life and his
son his father has made it worse
by putting him in that horrible business
he had him in so does president trump
appoint a special it almost even looks
like not only is she off mic
her camera almost looks out of focus it
looks like the focus is sharper on this
light than on her face weird
counsel before he leaves it's up to
president trump i mean
you know the reality is he could appoint
a special counsel and biden could remove
that special counsel
it doesn't really make a difference if
he does no and i think the press you
know if biden did it
it'd be the right thing to do yeah
because the press is so biased
you just watched newsmax tv america's
fastest
insane so that's what's happening on
newsmax and then
um hold on i did have a couple other
things i wanted to look at on newsmax
the things they've been covering are
just crazy
um oh let's see
let's see what this capital raid video
evidence piles up
the 12-minute new yorker video provides
one of the best looks
at this unprecedented event it's not our
chair
look i love you guys you're brothers but
we can't be disrespectful
don't disrespect them they can steal an
election when kids in their chairs no
we're not putting up with that but
others went ahead
going through papers and other materials
more than 100 arrests have been made so
far
federal officials are combing through
thousands of hours of video
so we're 30 seconds in and there's been
no mention of the fact that this was a
trump riot i'm wondering if that
gets i haven't seen this clip i wonder
if that's mentioned at all in this
they remain concerned ahead of joe
biden's inauguration
so much so that the national park
service has closed the national mall to
the public
until thursday as a precaution army
secretary ryan mccarthy says he hasn't
seen any evidence of a threat
but adds that commanders are on the
lookout for suspicious activity
we've also been vetting them through the
fbi
getting support from the federal bureau
of investigation to
to continue the vetting of every men and
women that come here we have a
process to our jrsoi process where we
vet them
so we're continually
going through the process and look
taking second third looks
at every one of the individuals assigned
to this operation
the vetting process began with the first
now
there this is very interesting instead
of focusing on the fact that this is all
necessary
because of threats from violent
trumpists as outlined in the fbi memo
they show a little bit of video and
it's video during at least one person
set
when one person is saying let's be
respectful in here
and then they focus on how they're
vetting the national guard
troops this is crazy national guard
troops deploying to dc more than a week
ago
which will likely be complete by
wednesday what's the reason
like we know that this this is necessary
because of the parlor posts
and the incitements from congresswoman
bobo the clown
lauren beaubert and others but the
it's like how do you even report on this
in this way incoming white house
communications director kate
bettingfield says there will be an
outdoor ceremony
even with security concerns i think that
will send an incredibly important
visual image to the world about the
resilience of american democracy
and so our plan and our expectation is
that president-elect biden will put his
hand on the bible with his family
outside if you do if you knew nothing of
what happened last week
and you watched this report you would
say who were these people was it just
random people were with it
was there a political orientation to the
people that did the riots we can't tell
you would have no idea who did the
rioting and who the threat is from
if you watched this side on the west
side of the capitol on the 20th
but washington's democrat mayor muriel
bowser is urging people
to stay home i want to reiterate my
request to americans
to enjoy this 59th inauguration of the
president of the united states and the
vice president of the united states
from home enjoy it virtually on january
20th
now despite the lockdown we had earlier
this still does feel like the most
safest
the safest city in the country uh if not
the world you have the 25 000 national
guardsmen here
super safe right now he's not saying why
they they know they don't say why they
need the national guardsmen because of
this violent trumpian group it's it
that's crazy
and i see that people want me to um look
at the new yorker
video uh i think we could do that i
think that that's certainly something
that uh
that i i would be glad to do um
in in a moment am i opening the phone
lines i am willing to open the phone
line so
we've set this goal of 232 supporters
today and the
that number comes from that's the number
of electoral votes trump lost with
and that's the number of members of the
house that voted to impeach trump last
week so it seems like a nice number
uh let's see where we are right now from
the standpoint of 232
we did get two folks who signed up via
twitch that puts us at 61. all right
that's nice
we've got stephanie la ferreira who
grabbed a subscription at
joinedpakman.com and suzanne
henniger who also signed up at
joinedpakman.com that's 63
and then some patrons anthony estrada
as well as dog of the sea
and lib tears yikes lib tears an unusual
uh name to see but lib tears subscribing
uh making a pledge via via patreon
okay let's get to
the new yorker video let me see the best
place to find it
new yorker riot video let's see if i can
find it that way
ah here it is okay yeah let's let's look
at this
i've only seen bits and pieces of this
let's get a sense of it
[Applause]
where the [ __ ] are them
[Music]
[Music]
okay so now they've fired these people
up into getting information so this guy
in the white
is photographing documents
oh my god there's gotta be something
here we can use against these scumbags
what
you use against what does he think this
is what kind of documents what a bizarre
reaction there's got to be something
in here we can use against these
scumbags
it's like a spy with a mini camera
photographing docks to send back
oh there's the guy wow so this photog i
mean if i saw this guy i would wonder
how is he gonna
react to me photographing him like this
the photographer was fine as far as i
know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i think cruz would want us to do this so
i think we're good
it would it's like a cartoon or comedy
film except it's real and that makes it
horrifying
uh-oh what's this guy doing
against enemies foreign
[Applause]
it's weird to chant usa usa while
destroying the us capital
you police
pandemonium ah there they go in the
window
that's after the window was broken
remember you can see the broken glass
guys why
why would you doubt that these are folks
for law and order and for
supporting the police why would anyone
doubt that
[Applause]
we're listening to trump
wow
this is seriously horrifying this is way
worse than was even originally reported
constitution defend your liberty defend
your constitution
defense reality
is he saying something about oxytocin i
can't tell what that guy is chanting
[Music]
1776
guess what america showed up where's the
rest of everybody
[Applause]
where the [ __ ] are they
where are they while we're here we might
as well set up a government
hey let's take a seat what jobs ex you
know i know a lot of people got
fired from their jobs after being um
caught so if you're just joining us
we're watching the new the incredible 12
minutes of footage
that the new yorker put together from
the uh trump riots and it's it's way
worse than than i
even imagined um what kind of jobs could
these people have like i know people are
getting fired and this is not about
ridiculing any particular job this is
like
if you're willing to do this and behave
this way what job could you even do like
a normal person for more than a day like
how do you you know could
could could a person behave normally
working at a car wash
who's willing to do this stuff is it
just group think that takes over and
people behave in ways
they would never behave while sitting
there you know maybe there's maybe
there's a male
person here or maybe imagine there's
maybe there's a doctor or a nurse i
don't even know
oh a nurse got fired someone is saying
um
there were some police yeah
yeah i don't know
[Music]
we paid for it this is our house
every single one of these people should
end up in prison and hopefully they do
[Music]
no this is our chair i agree with you
brother but it's not ours
it belongs to the vice president of the
united states when he's in here
uh-oh disagreement among the ranks
look i love you guys you're brothers but
we can't be disrespectful
don't disrespect them they can steal an
election when kids in their chairs no
we're not putting up with that either
pr warfare
[Music]
is did he call it an idol war or an idea
war what was that what does that even
mean
information information operation he
can't do it
information operation war okay okay
imagine having like what do you then do
like you get back home and if you don't
get arrested you're like hey look at
this document i have a picture of the
[Applause]
ted cruz's objection to the arizona's
objection he was going to sell us out
all along
really [ __ ] objection to counting the
electoral votes
of the state of arizona wait no
oh my god that oh that is genius did you
guys see what just happened there
did you guys just see what happened
there so the the guy in the middle
says look ted cruz was gonna sell us out
look at this
objection to counting the votes in
arizona and then this guy on the left
goes
no no no that's in a by remember he this
kid on the left realizes
biden quote won arizona so an objection
is good that's a good and they're now
arguing they don't even understand the
documents i i've got to go back and see
that again
so this guy's like look ted cruz was
going to sell us
out he was going to object to the votes
in arizona and then this other kid says
that's a good thing no cruz is good
i don't want to
[Applause]
ted cruz's objection to the arizona's
objection he was going to sell us out
all along
and someone's like what and another guy
says really
of the state of arizona can i get a
photo of that wait no that's okay
all right that's a good thing they don't
even understand what's going on these
people
he's with us he's with us he's with us
yeah okay good
like had it been up to just the big guy
next thing you know they're calling for
cruz's head
by misunderstanding what this even is
imagine this kid who's like like let's
there's got to be something here we can
use
imagine this kid leading an information
war that takes down the these scumbags
[Music]
[Applause]
then we've got the guy the viking dude
up there
that seems more that seems more of a
mental health incident than anything
[Music]
else
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here's this guy uh-oh this guy's since
been arrested
hey man glad to see you guys you guys
are [ __ ] patriots look at this guy
he's got
covered in blood god bless you yes
you good sir attention i'm good thank
you all right
i got shot in the face
did this guy say he got shot in the face
with some kind of plastic bullet
did he shot in the face with a plastic
bullet any chance i could get you guys
to leave the senate
pretty please guys could you go now
okay i just want to let you guys know
this is like the sacred place
[Music]
any update on uh the guy sitting up
there with the viking it has what what
are the charges against him what's going
on with him
[Music]
i'm making sure you guys don't do
anything else now that you've done that
can i get you guys to walk out of this
room please yeah
yeah yes
just complete disregard for the you know
these guys
they always talk about all these pro
just
obey lawful orders from police and
everything's fine just
law and order obey lawful orders from
police
you've broken into the senate chamber
and you're receiving the lawful order of
a police officer to leave
and they just ignore him they just
ignore him
i feel like you're pushing the line hey
come on man
oh is this the guy who requested vegan
food in jail
and he got it interesting
just be respectful to him there's four
million people coming in
so now it's 4 million
[Music]
it's only a matter of sorry organic food
not vegan food sorry did i say vegan
justice is coming
there were not four million people there
were not even one million people there
thank you heavenly father for blessing
us with this opportunity
thank god
thank you father amen
for this opportunity to stand up for our
god given unalienable rights
thank you heavenly father for giving me
the inspiration
it's interesting because by this point
it kind of seems to be petering out like
people are kind of
you know i mentioned this before i don't
think even they expected to be in there
that long and it's sort of like now what
do we do
and it's like when i get pranked calls
from people who think i'm going to
immediately
hang up on them but it's funnier to let
them go and then they
they run out of gas very quickly they
don't know what else to do
that this is our nation not theirs that
we will not
allow the america the american way it's
funny how these guys are all ending up
in prison
sorry jail jail arrested jail not prison
yet
thank you on the president of god
[Music]
harmony thank you for filling this
chamber with patriots that matthew
this is jus these it sounds like antifa
to me right this is exactly what antifa
sounds like
[Laughter]
peace and harmony thank you for allowing
the united states of america to be
reborn
thank you for allowing us to get rid of
the communists the globalists and the
traders
we love you and we thank you in christ
holy name we pray
guys we support you guys can't you tell
these guys support you and uh we
appreciate what you're doing we know
you're doing your job
[Applause]
right
[Applause]
this is pitiful and tragic and and
pathetic and you know it's insane
whoa hold on a second that doesn't sound
very pro-police to me
i thought it was about back the blue
huh
what a mob
[Music]
what a fiasco
unbelievable
that's obviously not mace do do we know
was that
was that law enforcement deployed gas or
what what was that i'm not even
what sure [ __ ] let's go
fire extinguisher
wow
[Applause]
now they're beating associated press
equipment
with a with a flag
[Music]
just uh this is you know the this is the
property damage of course that
uh they were previously saying
antifa should be you know life in prison
for here
so i hope we know who these all these
people are and that they've been
arrested
hey i may be insured but they should
still go to prison
is over there cnn is hiding behind union
station directing people to go to cnn i
don't know where that is though i'm not
from here
start making a list put all those names
down and we start hunting them down
one wow make a list and we will start
hunting them one by one
is he talking about reporters or what i
don't even know what he's doing i'm sure
it's not good
whatever he's talking about
you know it's interesting that he says
that i've done this segment now a couple
of times
where i talk about to understand the
mindset you have to understand they
they believe they are at war and that in
war you're going to have some casualties
and you'll have to do some things you
wouldn't normally do
um this guy's literally saying it we are
we are at war and you have to understand
that they believe that to understand how
this stuff happens
you there and there it is as i this is
literally from my commentary
they accept they will take some losses
in fighting the war and he's saying
even if it kills your feet
and take down every one of these
disturbing stuff just completely
disturbing uh just dystopian video it's
it's completely nuts and i i do hope
they find everybody
if people have other numbers let me know
the latest numbers i saw
are that there's been about 70-something
arrests
so far um or i'm sorry no
70-something charges
for a hundred something arrests some of
them have not yet been
been charged with about 300 something
people that they're looking for
does that do those numbers make sense to
people i know that it's still too small
it needs to get into the thousands
probably but
is that roughly what you've heard i
thought it was over three hundred
you've right i thought it was 300 people
they were looking for of which they
found about a hundred
381 arrests oh okay wow if that's true
that's starting to to make more sense
it's it's absolutely horrifying it's
absolutely horrifying um
i'm glad that we're building support
from great people like you
so let's take a break from that i want
to thank the 15 people
who just grabbed twitch subscriptions i
really appreciate you
i want to say thanks to kenneth anderson
and mark franklin for signing up at
joinpackman.com
which puts us at 83 and then we're also
counting patreon today
i want to say thanks to john rourke who
just pledged at patreon.com david pakman
show
rico b who just pledged
katherine and katrina
bukovac putting us at
87 today um very much appreciate it
very much appreciate the support this i
i don't
think i'm streaming tomorrow because we
we actually are going to record two
shows tomorrow so tomorrow morning i'll
do my tuesday show like i normally do
but because we're gonna stream the
inauguration wednesday at 11 a.m eastern
um i'm going to film the wednesday show
late tomorrow night and it'll be like
the biden's getting inaugurated show
we'll film that tomorrow night so i
don't think i'll have time to stream in
between
wednesday will be live with you at 11
and then the thursday show will be the
biden is now president show and i
anticipate
i anticipate that um by thursday we will
have a lot more information about
investigations that have been opened
into trump i know that that's crazy that
soon
but i believe we are are going to have
it okay
sorry i know i've been missing the um
super chats let me get to some of them
what should we name this event
dumb ghazi i don't know what the right
name is for the trump riot
i don't know we should we we need a name
that's for sure david please let me tell
me where you found that my cousin is in
that video i just got on
that's uh in the new yorker the new
yorker put out that video
only a matter of time until these vermin
are flying planes into buildings best
wishes from canada that's a scary
thought and i think that's exactly what
there is uh concern about
do you think these people believe that
trump would show up and they'd establish
him as a dictator i have that's a great
i have no idea
i don't know what they believed uh oh
i'm getting messages that there's
actually more video i should be looking
at
i don't know what they believed was
going to happen as a result of that
um let me see here hold on there was
another
there was another video people were
pointing me towards
uh where was that another video
oh no we've looked at that video now i'm
not not going to look at that
david this video is confusing because
the viking guy on this video
he is bald but on the mug shot he has
long hair
is not the same guy well listen the
authorities are looking into everybody
i don't i don't know uh i don't know
what else to tell you there's a bunch of
people at the caring that's an
interesting idea
the trump's erection uh any news on
elizabeth from knoxville aka mace girl
uh no i don't know i'm not sure about
that um
there is a yeah the anti do do people
want to look at some anti-mask videos
there was an interesting one from trader
joe's
i don't know if people are over the
anti-mask videos at this point
yeah i don't know i i'd look at some if
people are interested in them
yeah okay let's see if i can find it uh
okay trader joe's
anti-mask let's see if we can find it
uh anti-mask cauliflower karen freakout
oh man that is interesting is it this
video let let's see i don't know which
one of
these it is leave me alone i'm so scared
i need cauliflower oh my god
i know this isn't it let me just take a
look at this one though
did you want to call the police oh yeah
go ahead
call them miss we don't need to do this
yeah we're just here we're just trying
to run a grocery shop okay but you know
what
i have a minute can i help you shop i
have a medical examiner yeah i already
told her that
can i help you shop all i need is some
cauliflower pizza crust
well let me get it for you and you can
wait around cauliflower pizza crust i've
had that by the way
it's it's not it wasn't great but that's
funny that that's the only thing she
needs
and she's doing this all for cauliflower
pizza by the way i say
cauliflower not cauliflower but
that's probably a topic for a different
day
[Music]
and jump tim
[Music]
one of the things i'm noticing is that
the the trader joe's employees are way
too nice
to these people um okay
this is the one i wanted to look at
actually let's see
so there's two there's two i wanted to
look at one is
the trader joe's video that is covered
here i'd like the original video if
someone can tell me where to find that
and then the other one i wanted to look
at was there is a
um a woman who's at a oh it's a
it's a fast food restaurant of some kind
and
two police drag her out for not wearing
a mask
let me see oh this is it right here no
but this is also a commentary i just
want the original video
uh maybe i can find it on twitter
uh trader joe's mask
let's see
it's not that one i want
video but these are not see here
i know people know which one i'm looking
for it's not this lady
that's not that uh
kicked out and banned bagel karen
is that the name of it oh it's oregon
okay okay okay let me search for that
trader joe's anti-mask oregon
um it is this let's just see if the
source video
is in the description that's a fair idea
part one
part two no that's not there
leopard print
leopard print let's see
leopard print trader joe's
cheetah print karen yeah this is the one
oh no but this is again
i'm sure that the plain as jane is a
great thing but i'm just trying to get
the original video oh i think here it is
okay let's take a look i think we've got
it
yes this is it check this out these
people are way too nice way way way too
nice
to go in and shop like everybody else
i'm dave the manager
oh no oh my god we've got commentary
let's see oh no it looks like most of it
is without commentary
they can issue a fine but you don't pay
it because you're not guilty of anything
i'm gonna be going live yeah
how's it going guys good how are you
good good having a good day
yeah how about you good good okay i know
why you guys are here
i know you guys we're here to shop
absolutely yeah totally understood
peacefully shop
totally fine groceries no problem you
guys want to shop no problem
you guys just want to grab your
groceries
[Music]
be polite and respectful and respect
other people's rights because we don't
want special treatment we just want to
be
honored as yeah so they do want special
treatment in the same way that if
someone showed up and said
listen i don't want special treatment i
just want to go in with no shirt even
though
you require a shirt i don't want any
special treatment just let me go in
wearing what i want well no no
the special treatment is everybody else
has to wear a shirt it's the same thing
this
it's these arguments are so stupid oh
good
thank you thank you i understand all
that truly and like i was telling you
your friends over there i don't want to
tell you guys what to think
what to do what to believe it like that
we honor that i just
i would ask kindly that you guys
understand
see if i were this guy i like the idea
of saying
i'm not here to tell you what to think
like he's just running a grocery store
people in there i'm sure i'm sure white
nationalists come through there
i'm sure homophobes come through there i
like the idea of i'm not telling you
what to think but i would go a little
further and i would say
you just can't come in here without a
mask because we'll all get fired
and we'll all have a problem and these
are the rules
um i i think he could go a little more
aggressive on that
here exactly you just can't come in
without a mask period tj's
and what we're doing we're just trying
to work make living
but hey i get it absolutely trying to
make
isn't going to be made with us
we're just shopping with your government
well no no no we're talking about now
i'm not talking about the shopping i'm
not talking about this guys
you're right i totally understand that
you just have that
i am not here to debate policy here i
totally respect you
why why aren't these people mad that
they also have to wear shirts
i i just don't understand it's not
illegal to have your shirt off in public
so it's not that's not the issue but
they they only have a problem with a
mask because that's that's the only
thing they care about
you can't go in without shoes either do
they have a problem with that
i think whatever you guys want to think
by all means truly i believe that we're
demonstrating for that
and you have absolutely we're not
demonstrating i
they don't know one guy's like we're
demonstrating to make a political point
she says we're not we're actually not
demonstrating we just want to peacefully
shop they're not in agreement as to what
they're doing
buying groceries that's why i'm here all
i'm saying is
my responsibility as a manager of the
store yeah it's enforced and mandate
whether you guys believe in that
it's not a law but see neither is no
shirt
right but it's a policy and they can do
that
you can enforce non-law that's obviously
untrue
there's lots of things happening in
there that are not the law that are
policy
that's the choice of the business
no you can't that's uh you cannot deny
somebody the right to commerce
okay i'm sorry this isn't about right to
commerce that's absolutely crazy
that's insane all right i know imagine
getting thrown out of a bar for being
drunk and saying
you're denying me my right to commerce i
know you oh wait a minute
so they're going now yeah they have
masks wait a minute but you're letting
them in
yes they have a mask i'm just oh don't
touch me
don't touch me i you know one of the
things that i find really nuts this this
is a thing that's happened where
she tries to go in when she's not
supposed to and gets really close to the
guy and and the guy obviously is going
to repel her
and then she says to him don't touch me
hold on a second you initiated the
contact
i finally have a conversation but you
let no you let those people in we
all we want to do is shock i have a
conversation with you and i'm just
asking
we can do that we can do that inside
this guy is too nice
right by the way this is extremely well
handled by this by this manager
this guy clearly is going places um
and has upper management written all
over him because of his his ability to
just
continue without him escalating but
at a certain point you have to say i'm
glad to talk to you about this but
you're not coming in today people with
masks are coming in and you're not as
soon as you put a mask on you can come
in
it's you it just got to be simple you
know i'd prefer to have it outside no no
no no i will
it's not see that's where i think he's
not going hard enough it's not that he
prefers to do the anti-mask conversation
outside
it's only happening outside because
she's not coming in without a mask we
need to shop
no we need and by the way free market
right
find some store that doesn't enforce a
mask policy
if that's what you want there's a
there's no there's no right to trader
joe's cauliflower crusts for lack of a
better term
to shop
no you're not you are you are a place of
public accommodation
what that is you can be privately owned
but if you have shopping hours that's
right and we have a ride
nope that's wrong it's like listen if
you showed up with no shirt and no shoes
and they say you can't come in can you
say if you have shopping hours you must
allow me in of course not
of course not no that's not true you're
violating oregon statute
hold on what are all the things they
violated so far help me out chat they
violated her right to commerce
they violated her right to access public
accommodations
they violated um
oregon's statute which is a pretty vague
term what else have they violated so far
they violated her backwards thinking
yeah her freedom
her right to peacefully shop your policy
no we're not leaving i like the idea by
the way of peaceful shopping as if
non-peaceful shopping is common
the only people non-peacefully shopping
are people like her no no
can you mind us
[Laughter]
good conversation the conversation
wasn't that good that's where i disagree
with this guy i feel like we're getting
in good places
yeah yeah we're not demonstrating i need
to buy groceries
with audrey's workman we have options
for you no you do not
because i don't all right this goes
nowhere so that's that all right that's
one
and then let's look at i want to look at
leopard print
karen as well um
yeah this one's really good this one's
really good and we're going to watch
this one in a moment
let me just make sure i didn't i didn't
forget any thank yous
i do want to say thanks to the eight
additional people who just grabbed
twitch subscriptions i appreciate that
um
a few other new members to thank i want
to say thanks to lindsay
berger as well as jimmy upchurch
for signing up at joinedpakman.com
appreciate that
we are doing it's a triple threat today
quite frankly we're doing
patreon members
and twitch patreon.com
davidpakmanshow joinpakman.com
twitch.tv slash david pakman it all
counts today
let me just look at people's reactions
to this stuff i would quote the anti-gay
baker lawsuit for the right to refuse
service
very well said 75 in oklahoma stores
don't wear masks
fine but that's also because the stores
aren't enforcing it
karen shopping list cauliflower apple
cider vinegar quinoa
essential oils diapers johnson and
johnson no more maggoteers
shampoo nice nice uh nice shopping list
paul says pacman what has been been your
largest 2020 2021 donation
i think the biggest the largest single
donations
they're all pretty close on our website
the biggest membership we have is 480 a
year
and we got a bunch of those and then i
think the biggest super chat you can
send is 500 and i think we got a bunch
of those so i think it's right about 500
has been the biggest uh 2020 2021
donation uh okay let's get to leopard
print karen this might actually be my
favorite of all of them
this was a starbucks i forgot this is
starbucks not
i i think i said something else before
hand off of me
you are kidnapping me i want a person
you don't have the right sir get your
hands off me i've done nothing wrong
i am not a criminal get your hands on so
again remember that a lot of these
disputes are
the cops show up and everybody says oh
it's a cr i'm a criminal well
no the you're there at the store's
pleasure
and as long as they're not saying we're
not serving you because you're a woman
or we're not serving you because you're
white or we're not serving you because
you're
a christian right as long as there's not
a protected class violation
once a business says you've got to go
you've got to go
so they they don't seem to really
understand that
get your hands off of them ma'am
ma'am that's a violation take your hand
off sir don't go behind me
now the person filming is it her
daughter because later in the video she
says darling or something like that and
you hear the officer say
don't stand behind me so i think this is
someone with her constitution
okay so she cited the constitution let's
keep a list
she's so far cited the constitution and
that she hasn't committed a crime
you don't have the right to do this
you're taking the picture this
is so illegal you take your hands off of
me sir
i am not a criminal i've done nothing
wrong i'm asking you that
i'm asking you to get your hand off of
me i'm
in all seriousness guys if this was a
black male they'd be in handcuffs
already right
does anyone in the chat disagree that if
this had been a black male
who was not leaving after starbucks
called the cops they would already be in
handcuffs forcibly
does anyone disagree with that in the
chat
yeah okay
violating my personhood by touching
her she is being denied the right to
being a person
it has been taken away i have my first
amendment right
first amendment so now now i'm losing
track
i actually have to make a note so it was
a constitutional violation
a personhood violation a first
amendment violation there was one more
though what was the other one
that was violated
and oh not a criminal okay so so far
there are four different
explanations made here you get this i'm
asking him to take his hand off and he
has no
right to kidnap me oh and kidnapping
okay you are let go of me no
let go of me i'm happy to step out this
is the bible this is because the police
department are ignorant of their
constitutional rights
this is why this man has his hand on me
and he's
actually he's standing on her personhood
with his jack boot
he's jack booting her personhood i have
the right to protect
my personhood no sir take your hand off
of me
personhood's a legal concept right
like the idea she's talking about
personhood as if it's a physical item
take your hand off take books first okay
accuses of
purse theft purse
theft
i like how this now this guy is a
no-nonsense guy
this guy comes in and simply says is she
out of here and when he's told yes
they just carry her out
that almost sounds like a like a joyous
noise that woohoo
and now she goes with the i'm falling
down thing
that's all my prayers are you filming
this
are you filming this sweetheart are you
filming this sweetheart
stop it you cannot arrest now i assume
the sirens in the background are not for
this call
but there is a bit of an ambiance that's
added to it from the sirens in the
background that that does fit
although i can't imagine that that's for
this particular incident i've done
nothing illegal
i have done nothing illegal
stop it
oh no i had a friend who had a parrot
that lived a very long life that sounded
exactly like
that
put your arms back stop resisting uh oh
now we're
now we've got resisting they don't
usually pull out the resisting on the
middle-aged white ladies i have to
am not under admit leave me alone
after watching this video i thought
maybe this was about a leopard attack
okay so that's uh i okay i lost my pen
because i gotta grab that
yeah so this this is a mind virus that's
um
that that's spreading but it does seem
that she's wrong so
during this she made a number of false
claims
um she claimed that she was being
kidnapped
she indicated she couldn't be asked to
leave because she had not committed a
crime
she said her first amendment rights were
being violated she said her personhood
was being violated
the constitution was being violated
it's a two-minute video her purse had
was being
uh stolen um and she also wrongly
wrongly claimed that she was not getting
arrested
which it seems as though she was um
oh there's a second part hold on a
second
where can i find that where can i find
part two
leopard print trader joe's part two hold
on
um all right put parrot two
hold on where is part two can anyone
help me find that
i need to see part two
search google it was on twitter
um leopard print karen part
two part two of the leopard print karen
arrest oh okay
let's see here all right
put your arms back stop resisting i am
not under arrest
leave me alone i am not under arrest
i can't breathe i can't breathe oh that
is rich
oh can you imagine i mean after after
the george floyd debacle
i can't breathe is uh i mean think
that is that has so much other meaning
to it
that puts it puts this in a completely
different uh
the i can't the introduction of i can't
breathe adds another layer to this
all together let's continue
[Music]
[Applause]
no they're not can you imagine these
three officers are going to steal her
purse
yes stand on the sidewalk stop
interference stand on the sidewalk
it's a false arrest hold on i want to
add that as well
false arrest because they didn't say
she's under arrest they have no right to
arrest me
let go of me
police lack
arrest privileges
okay oh come get my purse no no no no
don't touch my purse come get my first
sweetheart
in the name of jesus no no
oh no now it went into another level now
she's invoking jesus
in the name of jesus i come against
these principalities and powers this lie
this
[Music]
yes
why do these always go this way like the
escalation the sequence is always
identical
i'm not trespassing you can't trespass
in a public business
they read the pro okay let's add that
cannot
trespass at public
business this i'm going to need a second
page no
they can't sir this is a lot no i'm not
sitting in your car
stop that you're under arrest can i give
her a card ma'am no you can't she's
under arrest it's her property you're
not getting reversed
wow so part two really escalating all
right so
the full list here is now i can't even
read my own handwriting
she claimed she was being kidnapped by
police she said she couldn't be arrested
because she didn't commit a crime
she said her first amendment rights were
being violated her personhood was being
violated
the constitution was being violated her
purse was being stolen
um she said she's not under arrest
she claimed it was a fake arrest she
claimed the police officers lack the
privileges
to arrest her i guess she means the
power to arrest her
and that one cannot be trespassed from a
public business and that was in about
four minutes
can you imagine
it's it's absolutely nuts
yeah okay so that's that i think that
that's those are all the ones that i had
bookmarked but if there are others i'm
certainly willing to look at others i
it's like how much of this stuff are we
really going to look at you know
um and yeah i mean i think for for me
the the
the thing that is always shocking with
these is
there are people who have ended up dead
for less
in their interactions with police there
are people who would have been
handcuffed much earlier on in the
process and would have had you know a
knee on their back and been flat out on
the floor
um you know i don't know
there can't be a part three is that true
that there's a part three
let me see leopard print karen part
three
yeah i'm not i think people are kidding
i don't think there's a part three
yeah no i don't i'm not seeing it um
okay yeah sorry if there is a part three
i'm unable i'm unable to find it at this
time
let me see what people's reactions are
to this
okay if someone can tell me how to find
the part three
part three is her at the police station
is that true that i have to see
i you can't paste links in the chat but
if somebody can in super chat you can
but someone can tell me how to find it
okay there is no part three fine we're
moving away from it part three is just
the youtube video burger and fries david
can you please upload this entire
section as a separate video
it's so insane and funny i need to share
your reaction yeah i'm up for doing that
um wow just wow these sirens actually
were for her which is great
okay that actually is funnier that's my
purse i don't know you
don't forget the defense i'm white she
forgot to bring the young priest and the
old priest
we need more commentary on this stuff
please dred scott i'm going to make
pokemon style karen trading cards
this one will have a screech power this
one needs scratch and sniff
for whatever reason whenever i see
leopard print outfits like that
i imagine the perfume that my great
aunts in argentina would wear
that i would associate with them but
that may be wrong i don't know
i'm a new member just found the show
glad to hear someone articulate things
so well and speak the truth at the same
time keep up the fight
she wants to talk about violation of
personhood she should read the scot case
to find out
how awful this country treated
personhood when it's not a white person
the sirens are an unending stream of
ambulance delivering ambulances
delivering coveted patients to the
hospitals that unfortunately may be true
and that's very very sad any more word
on the sketchy tours republican leaders
gave in days leading up to the riot
thanks for everything david yeah i have
a story planned about that for tomorrow
it would depend on the officer but the
probability of this getting nasty if
she were a black male is much higher for
sure
thank you kind time traveler for
inventing the karen meme
just in time for the pandemic yeah
um do you guys want to see my favorite
so-called karen video and i has it i
don't really i don't love the use of
that term
oh uh thanks stephanie smith for signing
up at joinpackman.com
we are just shy of 100 signups today
uh actually hold on a second 21
oh we did have another 10 people just
sign up via twitch sub i appreciate that
um
here's my favorite my favorite karen
video
let me see if i can find it the way i
know it is maskless holy karen
here it is oh i look when i google
search it it goes back to my own tweet
about it
this is my favorite one this is
maskless holy karen apparently
invoking some kind of religious precept
which dictates she should be allowed to
shop
to have an aisle to herself until she's
done okay take a listen to this
until this woman is completely done
finding
high fructose corn syrup drinks in this
particular aisle
jesus name commands you to clear the
aisle my friends
the power of jesus compels her to shop
alone
in this aisle
[Music]
i like how she's a if if i were ever in
a store
screaming at the top of my lungs at
people i wouldn't be able to
just go back to evaluating the you know
the unit price on items on shampoo or
whatever she's looking at
i would be too fired up that's right
until i can buy something and then i
will happily leave
i refuse you all and cast you into the
lake of fire in jesus christ
dear god
i like how this guy come this by the way
this was months ago this was before
uh this is crazy this was before masks
were as bro
as widespread as they are now um and i
like this this guy who comes over
visibly confused about what's going try
to buy on
have respect for jesus christ
[Music]
this guy is very calm kind of like what
on earth is happening
what is wrong with people like is that
the way you think you're really going to
get your message across
i don't understand what is happening she
doesn't want anybody on the aisle
until she can get what she wants and
leave the aisle
so she's rebuking everyone that is
rebuking
i have to tell you the narration lady
referring
to it as rebuking that's genius oh that
is just brilliant
rebuking it's brilliant
wow that i had forgotten how good that
one i think this one's
funnier now when was this from this was
from july yeah
with the hindsight of everything that's
been going on
the concept of rebuking is is absolutely
brilliant
all right i think that uh i i think
we're gonna have to leave it there
because there's just uh there's there's
just too much going on
uh thanks to garen collett and lauren
wallace
for signing up on my website i i very
much appreciate that that's
uh really really important stuff
uh okay uh now okay let's
let's now now let's deal with something
serious with these
with these karen incidents okay um
there's obviously and i'm gonna be very
serious about this because i mean when
you see it it's impossible not to laugh
but
this is mental illness right like in in
some sense
everything we've watched today
these are mentally ill people who should
be in treatment i think
i'm not saying medicated necessarily but
some of them for sure
and so like at what point
is it all beyond criticism because
listen a lot of the january 6th people
are mentally ill in some sense
and does does that mean no they don't we
can't charge them
does that mean we can't criticize i
don't know the answer i actually like
it is a serious thing as visually insane
as it's seeing as it is to see her
invoke
jesus name to rebuke shoppers from the
juice aisle
right at the same time we have so much
untreated never mind undiagnosed
but then at a certain point
fundamentalism is a mental illness
right almost anything taken to
insane extremes is a form of mental
illness
um you know take take uh
i'm and i'm not diagnosing anything here
not diagnosing anything but what i'm
saying is this is not someone with just
the wrong opinions
we can all say without issuing a
diagnosis
there's more to this than just having
the wrong opinions
you take i mean look orthorexia right
when people go overboard in
diet and or exercise uh
obsession that that is something that
goes beyond and you probably
should be seeing a therapist and um
etc but at the same time
we can't ju religious fundamentalism at
its extremes
is a form of illness of some kind and
we've interviewed
experts about that but it can't
simply be be called mental illness
and then it has no consequences the ma
the
masculist people still have to be kicked
out and then how does the
illness interact with privilege and
class elements and it's it's much more
complicated than merely saying
we can't criticize any of it because
this is merely mental illness
it's more complicated than saying
anything that presents a risk to others
simply has to be treated as such and you
can't account for whether the person is
mentally ill or not
it's often related to trauma of course
yeah so it it really is a complicated
thing
um
yeah i don't i don't know uh i really
don't know what else we we can even
say about it but it's it's complicated
it's complicated
a big thank you by the way to uh stefan
nikki
and claire who just grabbed twitch
subscriptions
i do appreciate that very much
and also a big thank you to denny dixon
and mia ham mia i don't i doubt it's
that miaham
but that would be kind of cool i'm not
gonna lie if it's that me a ham
that's i would take that um
but mia ham has signed up as well very
much appreciated
for all four parts look up bagel karen
all three parts and woman who refuse to
wear mask at einstein brothers bagels
arrested
she finally wears a mask in jail wow
that's crazy let me see if i can find
that
uh bagel karen
bagel karen all three parts oh i don't
know that i've seen this one
i didn't realize this was new
young man here i am at einstein's
in boca raton they don't know the
mandate they didn't look at the mandate
they're trying to now
take away my rights my civil rights as
an american my florida statue writes
760.00
and they don't have the right to do so i
thought it was point one to be honest
and we will see because i'm standing my
ground wait but this is the same lady
this is the
this is the leopard lady now i'm
confused oh
is this a prequel because i'm an
american and i'm allowed to breathe and
it's against my religion and it's
against the amendment
and it's against religion what amendment
are you a muslim
it's against the law for her to say
something she wants
you know it's interesting later she
said that it was against her first
amendment rights to be asked to leave
but now she's saying it would be against
the law
to say something which is really weird
may you
be healed and whole in your thinking in
your mind and in your emotions
okay you know what just hearing that
last line i think she's disconnected
from reality
this is america this is not a law do you
know that this is not a law
you need to go look up the laws of the
land
they're not a private
she doesn't seem to understand the
definition of a private business
open to like yeah businesses have
customers they have to serve me
otherwise it's against my civil rights
if they serve you they have to serve
me or it's against my civil rights and i
will sue einstein
that's only if they the reason they
weren't serving her
was because of her membership in a
protected class of which is of course
not the case here
i will sue this lady personally if she
does not wait on me because she is
violating my rights
would you believe that this woman
actually is a lawyer but her expertise
is in contract law and that's why she
doesn't know the law about this or would
that be hard to believe
this is what we are man and this is not
a law there's nobody protecting everyone
in here
he's the one that started i came in here
yeah i would love to know what her
religion is because she's citing that
but
it's not clear what that religion is
although later when she goes i mean
it's some form of christianity i would
assume i would guess not catholicism
you typically don't see i've not seen
catholic folks devolve into invoking
jesus name during arrests in the way she
did
so my guess is you know anything from
pentecostal baptist
born again something like that business
with you i have no business with this
man
has no business with me he's six feet
away from me he has his mask on what's
his problem his problem is
he wants to make a political statement
and stand like
and he doesn't know his constitutional
rights shame on you for not knowing your
constitutional rights sir
this is my first amendment right my
fourth amendment right
now and by the way this is against
florida's statute do you realize
florida's statute number 876.12
wait i thought it but first she said it
was point zero did you guys catch that
when she first named the statute she
said it was point zero i don't remember
the first few numbers
but now she says it's point 12.
that's interesting it is illegal to wear
a mask
in the state of florida and that is a
law and that is a law
know you're right young man
it's funny how like i mean i know that
i'm i'm i'm sort of like uh
applying logic where there is none but
she said at one point she said this is
an issue of rights but then she also is
naming statutes and like
state law statutes don't really deal
with rights
normally i'm not a legal scholar but i
know we've interviewed enough lawyers to
understand that
if you're talking about rights it's it's
not
a statutory issue in most cases
and also yeah okay i'm gonna yeah i know
i'm trying but i'm failing
florida why are you wearing suits no it
has nothing to do with my breathing
i don't breathe out of my feet
okay um oh people are actually pointing
out 876.12 in florida says you can't
wear a mask for the purposes of hiding
your face which of course is not what's
at issue here yeah that's that's
interesting
that's very interesting so this is very
sad and i
i really don't know what else to say
about it but um
you know it's it's it's a disturbing
situation
big thank you to sputnik 19
for gifting five subscriptions i
appreciate that
um and also a big thank you
to everybody that supported today uh
that's gonna do it for me just wanted to
hop on for a quick a couple hours stream
probably no stream tomorrow but i hope
everybody joins me at 11 a.m eastern
8 a.m pacific on wednesday morning for
the joe biden
inauguration very very important make
sure to hit that subscribe button
on youtube make sure you're following us
on twitch during this stream we we
surpassed 75 000 twitch followers
which we've never been able to do so
before to quote george w bush
so i appreciate it and we'll talk to
everybody very soon
you